when the coronavirus pandemic forced
much of the world into lockdown it
highlighted what social creatures we
humans are
more than half of uk adults surveyed
agreed that a reduction in social
contact during lockdown made life harder
social neuroscientist john cassiopo
argued that loneliness is an
evolutionary signal telling us something
is not right with your social
environment
and that you need to do something about
it fast
having really good relationships in your
life is fundamental to your personal
well-being
and being able to reach out to people
who really care about you
is so important so why does maintaining
friendships and relationships sometimes
feel so hard
we can all strengthen the relationships
we have in our lives as well as creating
quality new ones
here are some tips to help you connect
better with those around you
the first one is listen it's all very
well being interesting
but it's equally important to be
interested
in what other people have got to say to
you so really listening
helps people to feel more valued active
listening
is a skill one we can all practice and
get better at
when you're in a conversation non-verbal
signs such as
eye contact mirroring and nodding all
help create a positive environment
asking questions for clarification and
paraphrasing and reflecting back what is
said
also shows that you're really trying to
understand what someone is saying
being an active listener means that you
recognize that the conversation
is more about the other person than
about you
[Music]
sometimes you can feel lonely even
though there are people around you
making sure that the time you spend with
other people is of good quality can help
combat those feelings
switch off the television play some
games cook together
and communicate really talk to each
other and spend that time together
whether we feel happy and connected with
our loved ones may depend on the
activities we do together
one study found that our happiness and
feelings of closeness and more to do
with different types of activities we do
with friends and family members
as opposed to the relationships
themselves one distraction that often
gets in the way
is your mobile phone very often we can
be in conversation with people
and we're not absolutely present so
putting the mobile technology away
is a really good way to create that
connection
another skill that can help is talking
openly
author susan scott wrote never be afraid
of the conversations you're having be
afraid of the conversations you're not
having
if there's things that you feel
frustrated about and you need to get off
your chest
it's a really good idea to talk about
them rather than let them
fester often we might not want to talk
because we are afraid we might upset the
other person
or damage our relationship with them and
sometimes we just don't know how to
raise an issue skillfully
so firstly ask yourself what's really
bothering me
you can bring it up in an open and
respectful way
phrases like i have a concern or
this is how i feel when listen to the
other person's thoughts and genuinely
try to understand where they are coming
from
asking i am curious to understand why
or why do you say this can really help
with that
and don't forget to tell people how much
you care about them
how important they are to you and how
much you value them
it's also important to bear in mind that
you are never going to change anybody
but the only person that you can really
change is yourself
so sometimes rather than focusing on all
the things that irritate you
about somebody it's important to focus
on their strengths
another thing that can help you really
connect with others is kindness
studies have found that being kind to
others is linked to increased feelings
of happiness well-being and life
satisfaction
it doesn't need to be grand gestures
sometimes it can be the little things
that really make a difference
acknowledging somebody giving them eye
contact smiling
opening a door perhaps picking up some
litter or making an environment more
comfortable for somebody
or a compliment can really help to make
a person's day glow
there are many reasons why kindness may
have this positive effect
it can boost our mood and acts of
kindness can help us feel more capable
there is also some evidence it can help
us buffer the negative effects of stress
kindness is thought to be one of the key
ways that people create
maintain and strengthen their social
connections
you know we're living in a world where
we're more connected than we've ever
been
but really positive connections aren't
just about people
who like you on the internet it's about
people who are going to be with you
for the good times and for the bad times
making great connections in your life
is a little bit like building sturdy
bridges
because they can help to transport you
safely
through challenging times in your life
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video